la famille du petit et jeune cody
espérait obtenir un statut de réfugié au
canada en vertu du programme de
parrainage privé c'est à dire que des
groupes communautaires aux religieux aux
des membres de la famille se porte
garant des demandeurs et paient pour
leurs dépenses pendant un an
c'est la méthode privilégiée par le
gouvernement harper mais c'est aussi
celle qui prend le plus de temps
le délai de traitement de la majorité
des demandes et de plus de 4 ans et demi
un peu plus de 5000 réfugiés ont été
acceptés au pays de cette façon en 2014
pour un taux d'acceptation de cette
demande sur 10 il y a aussi le programme
de réfugiés assisté par le gouvernement
dans ce cas c'est l'état qui assure les
dépenses d'établissement des demandeurs
pendant un an les délais sont nettement
plus rapide
quinze mois plus de 7000 réfugiés sont
ainsi arrivés au pays en 2014 soit une
neuve demandeurs sur 10
le gouvernement fédéral paie les frais
de déplacement comme les billets d'avion
que les réfugiés s'engagent à rembourser
on peut également effectuer une demande
de réfugié en arrivant ici au canada par
exemple à l'aéroport en vertu de cinq
motifs la race la religion la
nationalité
l'appartenance à un groupe social ou les
opinions politiques signataires des
conventions internationales
le canada est obligés d'étudier toute
demande de réfugié qu'on lui fait plus
de dix mille réfugiés ont été acceptés
de cette façon au pays en 2014 soit
presque 9 demandeurs sur dix est le
délai d'attenté d'environ deux ans tous
les réfugiés doivent subir un examen
médical et faire l'objet d'une étude de
leurs antécédents judiciaires
depuis 2009 le canada s'est engagé à
accueillir 23 mille réfugiés irakiens
près de 22000 ont été acceptés au 31
juillet dernier depuis 2014 le pays a
également promis d'accueillir 11300
syrie'' 2300 été accepté au 31 juillet
le gouvernement vient d'annoncer un
nouveau quota de dix mille réfugiés
irakiens et syriens mais qui pourrait
s'échelonner jusqu'en 2019
comme terre d'accueil des rues
j'ai le canada qui venaient au deuxième
rang des pays industrialisés en 2008 est
passé au 7e en 2012 selon la plus
récente compilation de l'onu ici denis
martin chabot radio canada montréal